[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here with the
cyborg rat 7 mouse now just fyi this is
coming to you before part 2 of the
world's fastest mac mini series because
i am waiting on the ssd to ship so i can
do that video but i figured i'd show you
guys the mouse that i'm using and that i
will be using full time with the mac
mini this is obviously not your ordinary
mouse not a magic mouse not a magic
trackpad but it's the cyborg rat7 and as
you guys can see this mouse or rat i
should say
is an absolute beast so just having this
thing on your desk draws a lot of
questions like what's that beautiful
monster batmobile looking thing
connected to your computer but there's a
reason behind these looks as you can
probably already figure out this is
hands down
the most customizable mouse i have ever
seen if you can show me one more
adjustable than the rat 7 well please
show me but until then i give this a
title this gets the crown of the most
customizable peripheral so yes this
mouse will work for people with massive
hands or tiny paws so pretty much any
size or shape hand will work and it's
also yet adjustable to the point where
you can take the back off obviously so
that's step one step two is the screw in
the back of the mouse and if you unscrew
it enough the spring will release and it
gives you access to five small weights
in the bottom of the mouse so you can
leave them all in and have a heavy mouse
or take them all out and have a very
light mouse or use one or two or three
if you want you got to get the weight
perfect of course so
whatever you choose to decide you can
screw back in and have that amount of
weight now the rat is super duper light
step three in case you didn't read the
instruction manual yeah that's a hexa
screwdriver
unscrewer thing so that means you can
use it to adjust or even completely
remove the pinky rest that's on the
right hand side of the mouse naturally
you get two or three choices of pinky
rests when you buy it so you can look at
the link in the description to buy it so
you can choose to have no pinky rest at
all just by unscrewing it step four
means you can also use the hexa thing to
do just the thumb rest you can't take
the thumb rise completely off but you
certainly can tilt it what looks like
about 15 degrees left or right so just
to get it into your own comfort zone but
what better way to tour a mouse than to
count buttons
we can start with the red button on the
left hand side which is basically a
sniper button so when you hold it down
it lowers the dpi and slows the cursor
way down for those headshots or video
editing or anything else precise you
also have the forward and backward
buttons you can use these in the browser
along with the side scrolling wheel
which is always fun at the top you have
a profile switcher which goes between
three profiles red blue and pink and
they are all customizable in the
software in the middle you have a dpi
rocker which will move the sensitivity
of the mouse up or down and indicate
that with lights on the side of the
mouse so that'll go up all the way from
the lowest to the highest sensitivity
and finally you have the right and left
click and the scroll wheel for those of
you counting at home that makes this a
nine button mouse like a bows
so yeah the rat will work on just about
any platform will adjust to just about
any size or any shape hand and as a
bonus it kills all the bugs in your room
at night the only downside is it
transforms into a car a ferrari so
you're gonna have to pay for gas and
stuff no i'm just kidding guys this is
this is a top-notch peripheral i highly
recommend it unless you're a lefty uh
and i'll keep you updated on the world's
fastest mac miniseries which will
hopefully be our next video and until
next time mkbhd signing out
peace
[Music]
you